I want to meet professor Mahad
he won his Nobel Prize 490 oxide he
proved that little gas molecule is a
very important messenger of cellular
signaling
I'm styling autonomic nervous system
impairments these patients have a very
low life expectancy and I'm wondering if
we can change that I want to ask ferry
morale if we can develop a more specific
drug for this autonomic impairment if we
can target the nitric oxide so we don't
have that many many side effects from
the usual drugs that are using the
autonomic impairment you have to be so
proud of it just that's a little guess
I'm proud but I'm also impatient I have
a big laboratory because I like to see
results every day you presented a very
interesting movie yesterday do you think
that's very important to educate kids to
push them after the Nobel Prize was
announced in October of 1998 my office
got lots of phone calls from the schools
and colleges the universities everybody
was calling so I could talk to the young
people so I went to the television
Department of the Texas Medical Center
and I said will you help me make a video
what you don't know what the Nobel Prize
is we're going to have to do something
about that Wow hey this is coming out of
the TV get a gold medal and then of
course there's the money did you ever
imagine that it will be so important no
initially know initially I knew it was
important because that's how
nitroglycerine works and that was
exciting to figure out and then a few
years later we realized that did lots of
other things and now it's just
incredible mmm
they're now probably 130,000
publications I major because I've looked
on PubMed didn't so many how many to do
five pages and just the reviews there
are lots but there are applications now
for wound healing burns septic shock you
mentioned yesterday about septic shock
septic shock
if you
the production their studies with
hemolytic hypotension and subject shock
there will be applications and
inflammatory disease atherosclerosis
just lots of possibilities how do you
choose we have so many applications for
many websites how do you choose between
them
we always work on something that no one
else has done that's the fun part if
it's been done you know someone else can
do it if it hasn't been done then I
become very interested and think about
it and think about it and then to work
on it really takes the right trainee to
join me somebody who was also interested
and we try to work on it now it may take
three years five years ten years to
solve the problems but that's okay I
finished medical school I did a year of
neurology from residents in urology and
then I moved to Germany where in Germany
at the University we're trying to see if
different diseases that affect the
autonomic nervous system have an
influence on the life expectancy and if
they do we have a big study and
traumatic brain injury and we actually
found out that it doesn't matter if the
trauma is big or small it's the
autonomic nervous system is affected
then the life expectancy codes really no
we know that with brain injury with or
subarachnoid blades very aneurysms that
bleed into the cerebral spinal fluid
that the blood gets hemolyzed
releases hemoglobin the hemoglobin sucks
up the nitric oxide from the blood
vessels and the blood vessels will
constrict usually five six seven days
later they develop confusion because of
compromised blood flow I think I know
how to treat that I've never done it but
I think it'll work yeah because we had a
lot of problems with hemorrhagic stroke
and you usually you have to be very
careful not to do spaz and we have
calcium blockers wait they're not that
efficient and you have to be very
careful with those and I think the way
to treat is maybe we'll put viagra in
the brain to open up the blood vessels
our scientific sensation sweeps the
globe nitric oxide is everywhere this
common and Pudsey pollutant depletes the
ozone layer it's even found in car
exhaust and cigarette smoke but nitric
oxide is also found inside the human
body and could help send very important
messages nitric oxide at high
concentrations is going to be toxic this
is true of all messenger molecules in
the body you want to have the right
amount at the right time if you have too
little there's a problem if you have too
much there's a problem nitric oxide
comes out of chimneys and smokestacks an
automobile exhaust and it's a pollutant
it's toxic but if the right
concentration is very very useful today
we talked about being responsible
scientists do feel irresponsible when
the directions that the nitric oxide can
can only do or other scientists can do
with it I think one of the concerns that
I have is because nitric oxide does
there are so many things is it going to
be specific well I think you can work
with specificity because there's so many
enzymes and isoforms of the enzyme in
the pathway hopefully we can come up
with compounds that are selective for
one isoform or another and based on the
distribution of those I snow forms and
tissues we can begin to get a feel for
specificity we can also control the
route of delivery
inhalation gets different effects than
the intravenous or oral right so all
sorts of ways to play games I know you
worked a lot in industry in that drug
development do you see a future for
nitric oxide I think that probably every
big multinational pharmaceutical company
has projects related nitric oxide and
there are many many startup biotechs all
over the world how many I don't know
maybe 60 or 70 watts and they're all
looking at different aspects I can tell
you that you know the inhalation of
nitric oxide for premature babies with
pulmonary hypertension
and now they're beginning to use and in
addition the nitric oxide
phosphodiesterase inhibitors like viagra
viagra is effective enough there'll be
some other drugs coming along as well
why did you give up industry
I felt that I didn't belong in industry
I didn't agree with by superiors they
were scientists I couldn't argue with
them you know industry you don't argue
with your boss
you're just follow this power and I
don't follow I I do what I want to do
and I argue what I have to argue that's
its complications the other drives us oh
sure because I think competition is very
healthy because my parents they were
very not strict but they won't always
wanted me to be the first to be the best
I can be and I just at one point I just
started hating conversations my parents
gave me a lot of freedom to do whatever
I wanted I think competition is great
provided you win my parents I think
we're hoping that I would go home and
practice medicine I told him no I'm
gonna become a professor do research and
I think they're just supported and I
thought how do I respond and I said if I
go home and practice medicine in my
lifetime maybe I can take care of two or
three thousand people maybe help them if
I go into research and I'm really lucky
and do something important I get up a
lot more I think the advice I would
offer to anyone is to figure out what it
is that you want to do set your goals
and then go for it and be sure that
you're going to enjoy doing what you're
gonna do I did a year of clinical work
and I'm doing research and I'm just
wondering what I'm going to do next year
because I think research is a little bit
more hard you have to look for
fellowships for stipends for it's crazy
well I can assure you
good people will always have
opportunities do you think it's possible
do you do clinical practice and research
to combine them well that was my goal
initially was to do both youth loves
teaching however I learned that to be
the best doctor you have to do clinical
medicine most of the time to be the best
scientist you have to do research most
of the time to do both and be
outstanding with both is probably not
possible because if you if you're a
little bit of a doctor are you're a
little bit of a scientist you're not
gonna get patient referrals you're gonna
make mistakes and you're gonna have
difficulty getting grants there's a
researcher so you do have to choose well
I understand you know I love clinical
medicine when I do this I find
collaborators to do the clinical work so
I'm still part of it but someone else is
really doing most of the work basically
I have the choice to make a choice I
think so I'm surprised that there's so
many students here window who are still
trying to figure out what to do I'm a
little bit disappointed but I'm not
going to give it up I'm going to try to
do both clinical and the clinical
practice and research I'm going to try
it's gonna be hard but let's just see
she's got to decide whether it's gonna
be clinical medicine or research I think
she's interested in the combination but
that's a difficult thing to do today he
had some wonderful ideas that nitric
oxide can be very useful in patients
without animal dysfunctions that new
trucks can weed can be developed for
these patients so yeah it was wonderful
and I also learned a new thing about me
about myself that I don't have to be
that shy that I can talk to a Nobel
laureate and enjoy it and yes I
wonderful time